hey youtubers it's Charlie doctor who is
back this is gonna be my episode 1 video
whole bunch of classic whoo the episode
itself is like a standalone episode
wasn't that great like the way they
plotted it out but remember this is part
one of a two-part episode so I think
once we see both parts it'll actually be
a really good story just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet and new round of the giveaway starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so I'm gonna start with top 10
moments and then we'll talk about some
of the classic ooh references so right
off the bat starting it with the jump
scare number 10 the hand mines there's
really a whole lot going on here but
Moffat didn't waste any time and trying
to scare the piss out of you and I kind
of wonder if that's gonna be the theme
for all of series 9 just like a whole
bunch of jump scares just any chance he
gets one of the episode titles is even
sleep no more
the real jump scare though is when the
doctor asks the boy who he is
what is the name of the person I'm going
to save it's Davros my name is Davros in
Capaldi wearing his best WTF face
everybody that guessed Davros high-five
themselves they're a bunch of you guys
commenting on my last Doctor Who video
that you thought it might be Davros that
the doctor was trying to avoid moving on
to number nine meet konso democratic
snake creature that was is she probably
my favorite a little bit about it as
evil as he is all those snakes they have
a democracy it's like we're gonna be
evil but we're gonna give everybody an
equal vote the different planets that he
went to or all places that we've seen on
Doctor Who before so the first place the
maldavar IAM that bar is actually where
the doctor found handles and it also
showed up during a good man goes to war
the reason it's called the maldavar
eum's because the blue headed alien his
name was Dorian maldavar remember he got
beheaded and stuck in a box the shadow
Proclamation if he don't remember them
were really big during David Tennant's
run they're like galactic space police
the last time we saw him was during
stolen earth and that was during that
the Medusa cascade storyline where
Davros stole all the planets and pulled
him into the Medusa cascade moving on to
number eight back to The Sisterhood of
Karn we just saw them during the prequel
clip just setting the doctor up for his
call to action like finally getting the
message
Davros wants to speak to you one last
time on his last day of existence Davros
revealed so it actually like the place
where Davros is looks very reminiscent
of his laboratory during Genesis of the
Daleks
that episode really informed like the
second half like once they actually got
to Skaro it was all genesis of the
Daleks although there was some Hartnell
in there too it's just that when you
think of the doctor talking to Davros in
a laboratory like long-winded
conversations you think of the fourth
doctor and he definitely looks very
close to death on to number six Clara's
prepared she knows exactly what to do
the planes have stopped hashtag everyone
and she anticipates the involvement of
unit enter Kate Stewart and they kind of
explained before this episode that Kate
Stewart and the doctor were never gonna
meet the whole point was supposed to be
that nobody could find him it kind of
looks like she was using the same
motorbike that she had during the 50th
anniversary it's nice to see that she's
like a woman of action now like she's
just like BAM knows exactly what to do
in a crisis and Clara is the one to
figure out why the planes have stopped
because someone's trying to send us a
message of last resort one that we can't
ignore on to number five enter Missy
stage left when they were decoding the
message I just thought you know hey
Mickey you're so fine and then I thought
of Mickey from David Tennant's run and
was like maybe that's supposed to be a
joke for him I'm not sure there were so
many references to other eras of who but
most of them were too classic who so the
song choice could have just been a
coincidence the poor drink out for
Mickey if he got one to spare and
Michelle Gomez was totally on point in
this episode how's your boyfriend is he
still dead yep still dead who Danny pink
poor went out for him too my favorite
part though was when she slipped into
Scottish brueggen said I haven't gone
good like she went full Scottish and on
top of that we kind of get a peek into
Missy's head and in the way that she
thinks of herself relative to the doctor
like the way she thinks of their
relationship I'm as friend what do you
have to do with it I think the whole
reason for her Scottish moment after
that was just to say that you know even
though she really cares about the doctor
she's not going to be a good character
she's still gonna be evil it's just that
her relationship with the doctor is very
deep very complex wants number four the
doctor is hiding out in the past having
a party on his last day 300 years in the
past to be specific and it turned out it
was a Dalek trap the whole time
everybody was a Dalek in disguise
well maybe not everybody but at least
this guy that would actually be a moment
to get really upset about just because
it seemed like that character actually
had a real rapport with the doctor like
they had been friends for a while those
are the kind of twists I feel like
people criticize Steven Moffat for and
really the whole point of the episode is
just to get everybody
the doctor specifically back to Skaro
and it takes forever to get there so I
totally understand if you guys are
infuriated by like the middle twenty
minutes of the episode it's like really
strong beginning then a lot of like
running around messing around then
finally we get to Skaro and we get the
fun stuff on to number three back to
where it all began
Skaro and from the outside the city
actually looks the same as this first
Doctor episode called the Daleks where
they go to Skaro there were just a lot
of Hartnell things going on like even
the doctor's pants looked just like
William Hartnell's and when that Dalek
rolled out to meet Missy it was the
classic like the very first version of
what Daleks used to look like like the
silver and blue it was kind of hard to
tell but I also think that they were
using the voice from those old Daleks to
like it was a different sounding voice
than the more modern Daleks they just
wanted this whole encounter to be
something from the first doctor as
opposed to what was going on in Davros
his chamber which was a Fourth Doctor
thing for my number two i'm actually
jumping forward in the episode the
moment where the doctor says exterminate
and it seems like he's gone back in time
again to kill the young Davros to
completely avoid all the trouble that
they got into it was a great ending to
the episode but it's kind of a tease
Mama's just kind of slapping you in the
face
he's not gonna erase the entirety of
Dalek history from the Doctor Who
universe something's gonna happen to
stop him from killing young Davros but
finally my number one moment
Moffat goes full Genesis of the Daleks
he even uses audio from a Fourth Doctor
speech with Davros that was actually
kind of a shark jump moment for me like
I felt like they didn't need to do that
you guys can let me know though did you
like that they actually used the audio
from the Fourth Doctor episode or do you
think it was completely unnecessary
sometimes when they go way over the top
with the references to classic whoo it
kind of takes you out of the episode a
little bit
favorite moments of sound off in the
comments I feel like the Davros reveal
was the big one like that was the big
thing in this episode the thing we were
working up to killing Clara killing
Missy that's all probably to be erased
in part two of this episode just
remember when they got vaporized by the
Dalek fire it looked exactly the same as
Missy when she got vaporized by the
doctor at the end of series 8 so they're
definitely not permitted no no worries
there that's one of the limitations of
Doctor Who right now it's like you know
that the companion and Missy are gonna
survive to see another day so even if
they're still dead in part two of the
episode they're going to come back in a
very tight
anyway and there's no way they're gonna
destroy the TARDIS for forever but I
gave a minor WTF points for trying I
feel like if you didn't watch classic
who if he didn't know anything about
classic ooh this episode would have been
more scary when you've been watching
Moffat long enough you start to learn
some of the magician's tricks so you get
less and less surprised so I was
actually gonna do Easter eggs after this
but I actually I think I mentioned all
of them like all the classic ooh stuff
there I mean there were submission of
scarves I mentioned Hartnell's pants we
got a bunch of unit stuff that you know
there was just a lot of like visual
references especially to Matt Smith's
stuff like the malt ovarium part of
Doctor Who is watching the story just
having fun with this story and the other
bit like the other fun part about
watching Doctor Who is trying to spot
all the references to other episodes
sometimes it goes way over the top like
an episode like this especially with
Davros in it sometimes it's a little
more subtle but overall considering this
is the first half of a two-part episode
I had a lot of fun but if you were to
watch this by itself without knowing
that it's a two-part episode you'd walk
away thinking it was pretty terrible so
what's gonna happen next is I'll do a
Q&A that should post by tomorrow morning
but I'm also gonna try and do some Game
of Thrones and Walking Dead is Sunday
night well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my top 5
picks for the next companion and you can
click here for all my other Doctor Who
series 9 videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow